on the number line above the tick marks
are equally spaced and the coordinates
are shown of these coordinates which has
the smallest positive value so this is
interesting these are equally spaced we
start at negative eight and we have one
two three four five six equal spaces to
get all the way to 10 so what must be
the space between these tick marks here
well to go from negative 8 to 10 to go
all the way from negative 8 to 10 you
have increased by 18 or the difference
between negative 8 and 10 is 18 you have
to go 8 to get 20 and then 10 and then
10 more to get to 10 so this distance is
18 we've split it into six sections six
equal sections so 18 / 6 each of these
sections must have a length of three so
the each have a length of three so now
we can figure out the values of a b c d
and e a gets us to negative 5 i'm just
adding three each time b is at negative
2 and then you add three you get to see
which is at one and we've already
answered our question this is the
smallest positive value we have just we
went from the most negative we keep
increasing and this is the first of the
choices this is the first positive value
we hit so C has the smallest positive
positive value and then we could keep
going if you're curious d your add
another 3d is for he is seven and you
had three more and we get to 10 we
wanted the smallest positive value and
that out of the choices and that's going
to be c